[Music]
by the way i won't hear for about four
weeks because my headphones were
adjusted for the biden live stream
which got taken down from youtube as you
all well know but that was a slurp
on beat i love it how about that
practiced all weekend love us or hate us
we blaze trails
uh very excited for today's show by the
way we're going to be talking about
uh filling rbg seat we're going to be
talking about the update on the riots
recently
my name left the lips of senator ted
cruz senate hearing
and we'll be playing bad movie lines but
first uh my half asian lawyer richmond
is here and so is dave
landau from compound media there the
anthony kumia show hello everyone and
you have your own show can i say co-host
within or does he have a thing about
that
no he's good it's it's the anthony kumia
show with dave landau really it is
good for you it's very small yeah but
it's on there
next play your cards right you could be
doing a voiceover in wheaties commercial
i'm the sweet side i'm the tough side
boy i play a cop
a quarter black carrot is hey good
morning what's up dog
it's been a while i gotta get a little
rusty audio aid and
gerald a how are you sir i am well sir
how are you i'm doing is the baby
keeping you up will i adjust these
headphones no
no no my wife's doing a fantastic job
with the kiddo really i get a full night
so still married yeah
still married yep very nice absolutely
uh that's good this is about the time
that i should let you know before we get
to the question of the day uh we are
available also on
apple and android so you can listen to
the podcasts on audio
because a lot of people don't know they
want to take them on the road and we'll
be taking your live chat
after uh on mug club there's like 45
minute more show
yeah question of the day first is do you
think that president trump
should be uh replacing the rbg
seat the notorious rpg when they tried
to make her seem yeah they tried to make
rpg seem
like she was really hit right yeah she's
not 100 million years old right and
even even by that standard that's a
rough 100 million years ago it really is
it was not a she wasn't fit as a fiddle
no
right now but you found the fiddle in
the tomb
yeah very cool using a reference from
the 1990s
very very cool and i want to be clear
because of our new deal with um spotify
we uh have to inform that we do we don't
support filling the seat because rbg is
still with us
so we need to wait until the guest on
the show uh oh my gosh
oh she's just having herself a nice
vacation she's looking great for someone
from the late trial is that right rbg
i don't know why she's doing it she's a
bilingual
rbg oh i can't have joe lewis in the
studio because he tried to eat her
side-by-side oh wow he did huh um
she's bony yeah she's all boned dave
you're the only guest
uh a third chairman who i would feel
comfortable uh doing this with
oh well i appreciate it yeah i enjoy it
if you haven't had the target on your
back from the stuff that you've done
with compound this will be sure that
a little bit like predator it'll a
leisure i just want to make sure yeah
right in the center of my head
yes yes
um maybe i'll get to meet her soon who
knows yeah
what do you mean you're going to be
going to her beach house yes
i'll be breaking in and then write a
sequel that is sort of the
class study on a corporate cash grab
where they don't even try that
what you mean i think that's what you
meant so before we move on here uh to
the riots and to rbg
um uh jimmy kimmel hosted the emmys
yesterday yeah yeah
and he was talking with her to be honest
it was so painful to watch
but of course as always they have to
inject social justice and
it was even more uncomfortable
considering that it was pre-taped and
they were doing it without a live
audience
uh so we do have a video of the exchange
with and is it anthony anderson
so many kangaroos i can't keep track and
uh jimmy kittle because black stories
black performances and black lives
matter
say it with me jimmy black lives matter
what the hell going on up there louder
jimmy
black black lives matter ufo live on
another planet
born in home like e.t louder jimmy say
it
so that my pens could hear it black
lives
matter soft brown stomach protects my
knees and ankles from unnecessary wear
and tear
stanley and shut up in spanish that's
right
to be clear that's right that pales in
comparison to
uh my homeland's prime minister justin
trudeau
it does some people put them all in
black looks scared yeah
some people dabble in blackface his
trudeau is black it's his rezonde he's a
real blackface though yes i feel like
we've now just confused
a costume and black face right it's just
a strange thing to me
you mean the costume from jimmy kimmel
yeah it's just a guy i don't have i
don't have a problem with it
yeah i don't care but i do have a
problem with the guy trying to crucify
people for doing the same thing
yeah it's 100 yeah yes to be clear i
mean come on listen you think i'm
offended
okay that's my white privilege
it's just i'm a tasteless person yeah
it's your tasteless person privilege yes
it is by the way i love that we have
another another black man yelling at
white men to say black lives matter
louder that's always a good thing yeah
you're forcing somebody i mean
this is never historically believable
yeah like forcing them at gunpoint yeah
that was happening in portland
you've got to raise your fist and say
this is this old man who's confusing huh
black lives matter like say it louder
he's like i can't i
i did i have to poop and then they just
no
joke i was joe oh joe wasn't there i'm
sorry i thought he was yeah uh somebody
else
now we move on to by the way anyone here
have to poop
no no it doesn't save that for later
dirts from the programming in general uh
this is something you were asking me
audio wait if this was surreal before we
move on to rbg uh and the riots and we
will get to that
um senator ted cruz in a senate hearing
mentioned when they were talking about
sort of online censorship and this is a
really pivotal issue going into the
election because
people want to talk about russian
interference yeah what was it 3 000 ads
with 10
000 i mean that's something that an
instagram ass model
selling myfit spends in a week we're
supposed to believe that that would
tug at the thread of our institutions of
a constitutional republic no
of course not but big social media
they're removing searches they're
putting them down lower in the search
they've talked about they've talked
about how they will fact check any claim
of
winning the election donald trump on
election day like nearly every election
so
now all of a sudden the norms have
changed a little bit and senator ted
cruz was actually talking about his
discussion personally with youtube ceo
susan wojcicki this is something that
happened recently
uh let's roll clip let's talk about
youtube for a second and our time is
wrapping up here
some time ago i visited with the youtube
ceo
who reports to to google
and she described to me with respect to
stephen crowder another conservative
slash libertarian
comedian talk show host uh
who google demonetized she described
how the left was pushing youtube
to ban him all together and she sat in
my office and argued that we should be
happy
that that youtube didn't ban him they
simply demonetized him they simply took
away his ability
to earn money and she thought that was a
middle ground even though she conceded
that he'd done nothing to violate
violate youtube's terms of service
uh i would say it's weird watching that
it's gotta be unconcerning yeah he
didn't call you an [ __ ] that's great
but think about this we talk about sort
of how big media companies now
i mean was it the west indian trading
company like employed a fifth of
population earth but there's been never
been
a government entity more powerful than
if you take up the big three
right youtube google facebook twitter
yeah no and they have like had to call
me out by name
and talk about how it's worse than
caesar doing this
and it's like i just have to i was just
it was just a goof
i was missing a record and i don't know
if this is going to help or hurt my case
but it should help
you can't take all of this seriously at
least you're consistent
i'm consistently an [ __ ] that's
terrifying
it really i would i would worry yeah
well hirono what's the name of that
crazy bread from hawaii i
hate speech what she said you know it's
actually a good impression
i hate feet oh boy whatever the dish is
what's the dish it's not toy boy i don't
think it's pokey
listen stay on track hirono this is the
senate here's a pokemon
pokey i love a pokey and censorship so
uh
japanese now can't stop her she's hungry
i think
hawaiian hey everyone stop it's wrong to
hate that's true
it's true the only thing i hate is hate
yes
stealing speeches the only thing i hate
is hate itself
my god end of sentence
what's that crinkling uh happens every
time you walk
coincidence you're not selling me on it
um
potato chip
this comes after the biden stream by the
way was removed on youtube this just
happened
and thank you so much to people who
joined it live with credit.com we did
the whole stream there so
uh it also was a little bit more wild
and wooly because we were not
having to be moving to the youtube
standards it's not that different but
you know i may have made some
may have made some jokes about the uh
those of the homosexual persuasion
oh wow and and youtube claim this this
is at the exact same time
listen half vision bill i don't think
i'm speaking out of term when i say that
people know we've been communicating
directly with youtube the vox apocalypse
was because of us and they reached
out and now ted cruz has been talking
with susan wojcicki he says that could
be a long time ago
we were just recently remonetized so
cats out of the bag
there have been direct conversations and
you would think that being
the biggest conservative youtube channel
ever that you know we'd have a direct
line of communication when a
false copyright strike this happened on
biden's stream
uh and youtube said they responded with
when we receive a valid dmca takedown
notice about content that allegedly
violates the copyright of a rights
holder
were required by law to remove the
content we allow creators to file a
counter notification
um the key word there should be valid
yeah
yeah yeah exactly right but was this a
valid copyright uh strike
was it from someone at time warner the
pr was it the president was it jeff
zucker
i don't think zucker was on it so so
this is the problem
with an s when you have a bad law
with a company that doesn't even know
how to enforce it in the right way right
their system so the dmca they're right
the dmca does say that if you get a
valid complaint
that is signed under penalty of perjury
all of that and they represent who they
are
then you have to take this material down
however
this person is a known quantity the
email that was used to send
this particular request was already
flagged in 2019 and 2018
right publicly as someone who had
falsely represented they were part of
various media companies right
so is it and that's aside the fact that
this was not even a copyright violation
at all right well it wasn't a copyright
violation
it wasn't someone who had the authority
right to issue a copyright violation
and we've had several other false
violations right flagmas has there ever
been a single one that we haven't
fought and won no no every single one
but guess what you don't get that
revenue back
when you're doing a stream and it's
getting more viewers in cnn and it's
climbing you know 70 80 000
however many people are watching it you
don't get it back and then afterwards
just so we don't get back to revenue for
the year right
this is the unfair selective application
of the law
i want to be clear and i think dave you
and i agree with it it's not about
censorship if
youtube says hey we don't want
conservatives and we want joe biden to
be elected fine
now i think their their stock price
would take a nosedive but they keep
claiming
the opposite and in this case we have
someone who's a known bad faith actor
who's been doing this repeatedly
we didn't actually violate any copyright
and every single time
precedent has been set before precedence
could either could apply here i guess
no just the first one just the first one
i said it first but give myself some
wiggle room take notes joe biden don't
die on the hill when you don't know your
[ __ ]
well what president has said that we've
always fought and won so all i'm saying
is at what point do you acknowledge
hey we maybe should have an open line
and give the benefit of the doubt to the
creators who have actually been
we follow the rules the leftists who by
the way these laws favor because they
always want to silence speech
how many times have we gone around with
a false copyright claim
to get content or points of view that we
don't like taken down
none i don't think anyone in this room
has everything let me think
why would we care i want your ideas to
be out there if they're so bad people
can point at them and go yeah that's a
really bad idea they don't stand up by
the way
after all of these cop you know false
copyright strikes that we've gotten
through
what do you think they take five minutes
like tune to the show take a look and be
like hmm
nope they're not breaking any rules
maybe this is it actually
you have to have someone at alphabet
into the show and have an entire therapy
win
yeah they get one email from warner bros
gmail.com
[Music]
but isn't it just the ultimate hypocrisy
they're using the same thing that
supposedly got trump elected to
basically
get you off the air right exactly and
are we shooting a porn because there is
a fireplace here there is a fireplace
what's your
problem and he likes the warm fireplace
but uh
uh uh rbg has been well she's been made
of bones for years
you don't want him to grab that no no he
did before the show
all i see i think there were some tumors
on the bones for a while
yeah and i looked down and i see him
grabbing the
throat i'm like no not rbg
that would that would uh that would
instill uh mistrust in her institution
that crosses the line doesn't joe lewis
know she's fragile enough as it is
and this also comes at a point this is
what's so scary about this is there's
really no place to go
at this point we've been talking about
this they need to decide if they're a
public platform or if they are a
publisher
and you see recently there was a story
with spotify and joe rogan where they've
been putting pressure
uh on him and they want direct editorial
oversight
over the podcast because people who work
at spotify
are upset listen boot them spotify
fire those people it's a licensing
agreement that's what joe rogan has you
have no right to tell him what to do
unfortunately
we've seen a lot of the controversial
podcasts not be ported over to spotify
and uh i i i would hate to see the
content change but we do know that
employees at spotify
right now are wanting that to happen
like why do you want to you just want to
destroy all of the fun things
it's a 100 million dollar talent and
you're upset that some blue hair intern
is right yeah where's your investment
right no no our stock price went up 200
billion dollars but
she does have a [ __ ] hat yeah she does
identify as four things
so do you think we should get rid of
them tell us more about your [ __ ]
is it wet yeah that says they bring in
cardi b i do not think that you should
have joe rogan on your show because
i cut my [ __ ] when i was cleaning
with my pinky nail
that's almost nonsensical that's gonna
mess your balance up it's gonna miss
your balance so
what i've been walking with a limp and
since my weight carries low
it really affects me more like one of
those dogs are like you punch and it
comes back up you like the [ __ ]
why are you letting joe roger go down
though after eating a hot dog
that's gonna make you sick all i'm
saying is shouldn't be on
air and y'all gotta know how to clean
your [ __ ] that's what i'm saying
booty hole clean
oh you haven't if you haven't been
following uh cardi b's instagram yeah
that's not funny to you it's just
horrifying
as it should be yeah yeah i believe
those are direct quotes
this was basically news if you haven't
been following oh this is what she's
saying
oh speaking of news let's go to cnn
really quickly what are you talking
about
tennessee the university of florida
college is canceling spring break
to help slow viruses what about uh what
about the folsom street fair
never did that for hpv
yeah nothing like canceling spring break
seven months in advance
yeah i mean i don't know what they're
expecting at this point let's just close
all of the things and why is this lady
talking about it she hasn't seen spring
break in a decade
here's that's one of those weird things
you can see listen a pretty woman but
you know how you can tell
is because the face it like the face is
completely smooth
and then it's like uh like her her arms
are like an ex body
her next like an ex bodybuilder's arms
oh like with a vaseline
degeneracy yeah she has the jim henson
kind of beak
yes yeah yes the dark crystal yes very
much
like she just had a paddling in your
chair
that's exactly right the point is scary
don't trust her in spring break
uh let's go back now and look at the
riots because this matters since
uh rbg's death the left they've of
course surprise surprise vowed more
extreme very peaceful course here's the
thing mostly peaceful
threats don't work when you've already
done the [ __ ] that you're threatening to
do
right people understand that we're going
to burn your cities down
this is already there
you're in a penthouse look just i don't
even look just get the telescope out of
the way and look
with your eyes what you're threatening
to do we're going to do more of that
okay well i'm going to leave yeah it's
like the bond villain hitting the bomb
and then the rest of the movie happens
right oh well i already did it
making you talk what are you going to
have the laser slowly
creep up my girlfriend the love of my
life's crotch area until it
no i've already shot her in the head
that last song was so depressing i just
thought bond was going to kill himself
sam uh what's his name no no it wasn't
sam it was the other one the
the girl oh really eyelash yeah yeah
yeah yeah
that movie hasn't come out yet oh yeah
it's very whispery
i think it's just i want to die we'll be
there yeah
again tomorrow forever dying another day
that's so depressing but it's going to
sound like pseudo lord yeah
license to die another time what did
that happen with every single film
preview it's like gloves
can you be creative with anything it's
either that or the entire movie
right yeah that's the other trailer yeah
wow it just ended or
no movie sometimes like just a bunch of
jump cuts yes what is this
i get that you're you're this oscar
basically i saw sean penn crying
okay is it his daughter fight but what's
the film about then you show up you're
like oh pedophiles
[Laughter]
i mean i want everything yeah but how
would they get you to watch it if they
said that in the truth that's absolutely
true
uh worked for cuties so uh rpg they've
been threatening more violence and you
know what they are here's something
people don't they already got started
over the weekend so
rpg died if they fill this seat this is
the controversy right now people are
saying it's hypocritical for republicans
for donald trump to fill this seat this
empty seat on the supreme court which
again you know
it's more so that she's stepping over so
we don't we want to be clear don't buy
the fake news
um they did protest they did threaten
more violence and they already got
started underway this weekend
but don't take my word for it
the riots
[Applause]
someone squeaking a dog toy
oh look at this dog this one's creepy i
hate that yeah i really hate this
yeah the reason that dog if you guys can
see look you'll see the dog at one point
yeah the only reason the dog didn't maul
them was because they had it i want to
be really clear and a half asian people
might not like me saying this but um
if you reach in my car betty and joe
lewis will cause
permanent harm to you and you'll be
rewarded with every cheese i can find
and i feel it needs to exit the vehicle
right what you put in the vehicle will
remain in the vehicle
five exits down yeah it'll just be this
blood squirting arm and then yeah
i mean we've all seen jurassic park
about what happened they could smell
your jugular that's the point
yeah and i believe they had a what a
massachusetts plate that was his
violation
was it i think that's what it was well
they were actually there to protest yeah
yeah
they're they're approaching friendly
fire yeah it was friendly fire i really
hope they understand outside
see how everybody else feels see no they
don't care they're not gonna they're not
going to understand this moving forward
they're just going to
go burn other people's stuff and i will
tell you this this is like when they
were beating up that raccoon the black
lives matter activist
listen i know people say well you're a
meat meat-eater i am i am
it's not purposeless needless
meaningless death
context matters yes i eat meat
i don't go out and throw a rock at a dog
for no reason
yes i eat yes i enjoy venison yes i
might go for a deer hunt this year
i wouldn't beat a raccoon with a stone
just to prove a point yeah and was the
raccoon a cop
i would have assumed he was on their
side it's the one animal that always has
the mask they're bandits every time
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's permanent and it's about as
effective as those people who always
wear a mask they come out at night they
don't have jobs
they should relate they're looting
masked animals yeah they don't ask to
take your garbage
they don't they just have animals they
should be your mascot if anything
think about it yes wait so wait a second
worst animal to kill
a raccoon's like the common enemy that
we all need to bond around and be like
oh oh yeah they're here yeah they're
going to get to eat our rotten eggs oh
it's really more of a
i think you're talking about sacrifice
this doesn't feel right yeah i don't
know
i'm talking about hatwear oh oh well
you know i'm talking about jv yeah i'm
talking about
good stuff faceware because i unlike
dave landau believe
the scientists um
[Laughter]
so let's review this really quickly now
they're protesting even more uh the
george floyd
based riots right started in um i
believe late may
may yeah that's when they started yeah
uh about yeah right it was right after
the
quarantine month yeah or memorial which
the worst you know what though it did
sort of
it was memorial day that's right it
wasn't labor day because i'm gonna say
sometimes they're still rioting
and i've seen a few what pairs of white
pants oh no
yeah you shouldn't it's never tacky i
know i think that's the cause of the
ride
you're going to be throwing bear mace on
a cop
can you at least respect our social
norms no white pants after labor day i
mean if you're going to loot a macy's
they have
pants they do you have no excuses
just don't take the white ones um
first week of protests there were 13
people killed
right 13 people killed since then
they've killed more over 30 people have
died at the protest
over a thousand law enforcement uh
casualties injuries and people who get
mad saying well you say casual these
casualties do include deaths and
injuries
um and uh we've always said this we're
like well the number was 700 million
dollars and it never went up
we were talking and i'm going i'm pretty
sure significantly more cordon axios
it's minimum
uh one billion dollars likely two
billion and you know it's
higher than that this is coming from
insurance companies at this point not a
government agency who wants to say all
is well
yeah the insurance company's like
actually no it's not
because people are collecting claims and
[ __ ] and we're
our patients has sort of run out you
know insurance is sort of fire safety
but
not literal perpetual fire safety
um then over the weekend i just can't
wait to see
like morgan freeman or one of those
all-state riot commercials
yeah for surprises black guy from 24
other black yeah
[Laughter]
are you in good flaming hands i don't
know what is happening
is your car burning and your house and
your business
because it matters with our good
homeowner award program you can place
this spotter in your house that
lets us know if you have not responded
in protecting your own property
we suggest putting up a blm flag as if
it's the bible
it may pass over and we encourage a
reaction of serious surprise when they
eat their own
[Laughter]
ah shoot them somehow it's your fault
yes
oh you know pretty much if you're just
white uh just white don't plan on
getting to that claim anytime soon are
you in good hands
too bad i didn't dress like i did in the
90s i was barely white
were you that guy oh i was were you
wearing the mc hammer pants
i wasn't quite that but i definitely had
the adidas track suit the figure
i uh i definitely enjoyed my my drugs
you were flavor dave i always play the
dave
david so much i was wondering why he was
speaking that way when he came in yeah
and you want to call he turned it off
yeah i would love to have a coffee
flying
a day what are you doing dave
you're no longer welcome here no that
makes sense please leave so let's go
over the weekend there were some very
specific threats okay university of
waterloo the political science professor
emmett mcfarland that's not doxing
because he tweeted this publicly burn
congress down
before letting trump try to appoint a
new school yeah
then we have reza aslan who i believe
was a cnn contributor and uh yeah uh
personal favorite of the young turks for
a while true
um and he also ate human brains on tv so
i don't think he has that much
problem with the raccoon deal he said if
they even try to replace rbg
we burn the entire effing thing down so
these are you know it's one of those
deals where they say hey your silence is
violence right like you're silenced and
not speaking out and holding up your
fists and saying black lives matter is
violence
do you mean because you're going to
punch me in the face even though i'm 65
and my own prius
afterwards i guess technically a form of
inviting violence these people invite
violence
by actually inviting violence actually
encouraging violence and then people
act out on the violence and i do want to
know listen not every protester is
violent correct but come on
over a thousand officer casualties over
two billion dollars in damages over 30
deaths at what point do you say okay
it's not really peaceful and by the way
kyle written how's that guy rosenbaum he
shot
people have been talking about you know
what that guy raped five kids yep
he could go read the police report yeah
yeah he didn't just sexually accost
he didn't just show them naughty
pictures he raped five
kids but what did he do wrong
but no steven you're forgetting kyle had
a weapon
yes yeah that is much worse and believe
me correct
not lost on me the fact that he was
blown away by a minor is delicious it's
so good
it's so good he was chasing yeah
a minor yeah and was blown away by a
minor
it's the perfect way to go doing what he
loves chasing i mean you literally could
find like a hannah
meets that other movie that uh phoenix
just made that's terrible what
uh the guy that goes to phoenix his
brother died
yeah references to the movie where he
goes on and he kills pedophiles
and then you just oh yes yes yes yes and
you mix that with him well i'm hardly
here or whatever yeah yeah yeah which
confused me because of the same title as
was it like i was never he
was one where he played the rap thing
yes i just noticed the clef lip
yeah and also he broke his cla he has
like a weird broken clavicle like he's
like he's a walking prawn yes and he's
got the beard in it he's just
yeah yeah you do wonder how much of it
is like good acting versus he's just a
disturbance he's just a weirdo yeah i
don't know
you can fit him in the right role works
so this is where we are right now with
this violence and how
they have yet to to condemn it entirely
on the left calling out antifa and black
lives matter
uh but i do think listen i've talked
about you forfeit your right to live if
you play the knockout game
if you break someone's car with a rock
if you aim a rifle into a car
i said that's different from deserving
to die crimes worthy of capital
punishment
raping five kids for me you deserve to
die doesn't mean that kylo ren has had
the authority to
execute that person exactly but if we
are going to act like these people
and by these people again this rosenbaum
guy white so let's not try and hang me
on that though he did use the n word
repeatedly
not every single one of these people is
a multiple
serial time felon the kind of felonies
that not just okay he knocked over a
liquor store
the kind of crimes that make you sick to
your stomach
listen you cannot separate the two at
this point when the people who
you paint the murals for are all awful
human beings
who you not only would you not let alone
in a room with your daughter
you wouldn't let them look at your
daughter they wouldn't let them within
the vicinity of your daughter yeah yeah
but if you if all you watched was cnn
you would have no idea that cities are
burning across america when these riots
are happening and of course they're
already peaceful
look if we want to we've said this
before if you want to compare what a
peaceful protest is
in a time where we thought things needed
to change you can look back to the the
tea party group right they came into
places they protested they were very
vocal about what they believed and then
they left and cleaned stuff up as they
left right that's
you're comparing if you want to have a
litmus test a bar to hit
that's it not these mostly peaceful
protests well rosenbaum only raped five
kids he was mostly
mostly rapey for his life if you count
all the kids that he met
he was a most exactly mostly non-rapey
yeah yeah most of the time joe biden
that's true love them they'd never get
through silent night yeah forget little
drummer boy
he wanted to be santa sniffing like me
with my slurping um
so this violence now is because they're
thinking about replacing rpg and they're
saying this would
this would set a crazy historical
precedent this is a violation of all
norms they're trying to point to
republicans
for being hypocrites right now or
conservatives and uh i don't know what
you think
i don't buy it let me make what are we
about to say i was going to say how was
it a
republican's fault she got diagnosed
with terminal cancer in 2009
and just waited to die that's trump and
that's it definitely
trump she could have stepped aside then
right trump left her water bottles in
the car
is that what happened to her somebody
left her in the car outside of a rehab
he lightly coated
all of her mugs with bp it just melted
like a baby in the backseat
and and then and then he also installed
a plant for her assistant and she didn't
rinse her fruit
yes oh yes he's very clever with that he
plays the long ball
um so now they're saying this is
historically impressive and here is
and this is actually another quote from
joe biden which uh
i wouldn't say i i love but um let's
show it anyway
her granddaughter said yesterday
and said publicly rbg's granddaughter
right her dying words were
quote my most fervent wish
is that i not be replaced until a new
president is installed you speaking at a
public pool
[Laughter]
usually not as a personal service to her
but as a service for the country our
country
at a crossroads now watch this dive and
the camera pants is a six-year-old
chinese girl
okay what's up um cannonball
by the way i'm also pretty sure that
rbg's last at that point the last day
the words were
okay this lady was serious it was it was
two days prior to her death
and one lady's last words are only a
basis for a system of appointing new
supreme court justices
think about this first who cares yeah
and she knows that as well as anybody
are we supposed to just honor everyone's
what if donald trump were to die
tomorrow and he just said and my last
wish
is no other president ever
yeah how about muhammad's last word kill
all the jews
that's tough a few honored that yes one
guy
really tried yes i'm sure he had some
pretty tasty last words
too we probably shouldn't be following
but this is just such a lie that they
try to make this like
magical idea that she was like i don't
want to be
she didn't know anything she was just
like is that my mother
she gambled incorrectly on hillary
clinton that's what happened that's all
she's like
[ __ ] i screwed up
she's also somebody who called uh colin
uh kaepernick you know
disrespectful for kneeling and now all
of a sudden you see those exact same
people just going crazy online it's like
it's gotta suck to find out uh your hero
died the same day you realize that was
your hero
yeah and she also by the way said that
she didn't want to pack the supreme
court with more justices
she did say that she the nine justices
but when you look at joe biden these
other people who do want to add to the
supreme court now
i know what people are making the
argument and i want to really quickly
uh clarify this and then i'll use some
historical precedent the difference
between barack obama and merrick garland
that's what people are pointing to right
his last year of the presidency he
wanted to appoint a justice and the
senate blocked it they go well you can't
do that now that was 11 months right now
it's within a month of election
okay the difference here between the
scalia death
and garland merrick garland and rbg is
barack obama was a democratic president
yep
and you had a republican senate so
before we even get into decorum and
history listen it's as simple as
barack obama used his absolute authority
as president
to select a supreme court justice to
nominate and then the senate used their
absolute authority
to reject it in this case the exact same
scenario
donald trump has the authority to
nominate a supreme court justice and the
senate has the right to confirm
it period that's really what it comes
down to and that's why they were saying
it was historically unprecedented
specifically for a divided government
let's be really really clear on that
it's not inconsistent at all
with what's happening now and all
something that people need to take into
consideration
that also was effectively a vote of no
confidence when they have a democratic
president and then they elect a
republican senate well guess what
they've not only elected a republican
president at this point but they've
added seats to the republican senate in
2010
2014 and the most recent midterms
consistently i think it was six seven
and two
or nine seven and two so there hasn't
been a single midterm where they haven't
added senate seats
the people have spoken donald trump is
the president it's a republican senate
they have the right to nominate a
supreme court justice
and uh that's what they should do now
this does what she wishes though
she has wishes but she did final
thoughts she coughed
that's true guys she's right here we're
talking about her
oh yeah like she's not even in the room
you know listen she's being a good sport
and we turned off her microphone
i mean she's having fun look at her man
also her ventilator
ouch she's not wearing a mask this is as
good as dad
you know what listen at this point on
our side it'd be a covet is a sweet
release so
there's been a supreme court uh there's
been a scottish vacancy i want to be
clear in an election year 29 times
this 29. the president made a nomination
in
all 29 cases that's a precedent
10 nominations were the scenario that we
are currently facing now right with the
same party controlling the senate nine
out of those ten were successful supreme
court nominees
that these happened within an election
years president senate
same party nine out of the ten were
seated
what's the term should i say seated
appointed appointed appointed
well confirmed over there and confirmed
here's the thing and this is the point
you're getting to which is what are the
powers and what does the constitution
and the applicable laws say
and they say if you get through the
appointment process and you get through
the confirmation process
you're in i agree that there were some
stupid comments made
back in 2016 by some republicans that
are now coming back to haunt them
literally by word but the
the literally the system itself is still
there right the nomination can occur
and on top of that the confirmation can
occur we have the ability to do it it's
not unprecedented to be able to do it
but what is unprecedented is how the
leading two candidates both of whom are
women
are being excoriated by the left about
all of their policy get this one of them
is a latino woman out of florida
so apparently nerves now now it's just
like oh i can't believe you would
nominate the second latino woman because
she's
conservative right of course and then
the other one oh oh we really don't like
her because she's a woman
and uh you know what she's too catholic
way to win the latino vote dems
[Laughter]
there's some latino lady letting a
candle there okay
[Laughter]
yeah that's what you want to lose every
single person who has a half
what bathtub with mary on it
oh the one out of florida right you know
so her family escaped from i don't know
cuba
right uh so you know that's what we
definitely don't want we don't want
anyone on the supreme court whose family
knows the danger of communism who wants
someone who's actually experienced the
dangers of socialism as opposed to
barack obama taking a photo op in front
of
che who also was gay what are we about
to say there dave what's up
i was just saying how much i enjoyed
chase gayness yeah
absolutely that's why he executed too
many of them
don't protest too much jealousy
talking about it
this election year argument what would
you boil down the presidency to
essentially two years
rager against the machine left that out
of there they did the test their t-shirt
they did i mean they're they're going to
be they're going to zoom out and it's
just a but
yeah all right that's terrible
they're going to i mean you're going to
vote on this shut up go ahead they're
going to vote on the senate every two
year to your right you have midterm
elections right you're gonna have people
being voted on in the senate and you
have a presidential election
every four years right so really we
don't get to govern at all the
presidency really is
well you get your first hundred days and
then after that we don't want to hear
from you again and then you get your
next hundred days after that senate
stuff has happened and then we don't
want to hear from you again because
presidents are voted in for three and a
half years i think and not actually four
you know sorry that i really guess
[ __ ] need to watch some schoolhouse
rockets yeah i don't mean conjunction
because you already know their function
but there's a bill
sitting on the capitol stamps we'd like
to speak with you um let me be clear
about what lindsey graham said because i
understand
there were some republicans who followed
suit and didn't actually take the
context the full context of right and
right
because now they're trying to use his
words against him and let me be cl it
would be like me when i've talked about
in this show listen
youtube can do whatever they want it's
not censorship because it's not the
government but what is corporate
censorship
is when a company says or claims that
they have certain rules and they apply
them selectively and with different
standards
i've made that clear you can probably
find an interview down the line where i
would say well listen people are tired
of the censorship occurring on social
media
because not every single time do i have
the seconds available to go through the
races and that's what happened with
lindsey graham let me be really clear
in his argument that he made he said
well merrick garland was a different
situation you had the president of one
party nominating
and you had the senate in the hands of
the other party a situation where you've
got them both
would be different and by the way you
know who else made the argument that you
should appoint supreme court justices in
the last year
joseph biden back in 1992 before the uh
the the cerebral uh plaque for the set
in deterioration
the great matter left the gray matter i
don't know if black is gray man or white
how it shows up on your brain i'm not
sure i have no idea if it's white let's
see brain scan i can see your plaque
i have no plaque that's the kind of
thing if you just wanted to get joe
biden just like that you say i can see
your brain plaque
no you cannot
prove it i'll prove it yeah push-ups hey
would you like one-armed push-ups with
the left side of his face with going
like this
yeah if he if he had more strength he
just beat jack palance right now i
guarantee it that's all he does is get
violent just like shoves people
or he'd be like attempting to be a jack
lalanne not successful he would just be
instead of his uh dog sprite he'd just
be kicking his dog
get out of here give me my juicer he's
just drowning with a rope attached to a
piano
[Laughter]
like a water moccasin just ahead
bye-bye anyone who does not uh is not
familiar with jacqueline's feats of
strength shame on you that was funny so
he made the case in 1992 he even made
the case for the precedent being
predicated on this idea of a divided
government
go and read a statement you have the
link right there and the overlay read
his entire statement in context
it could read like lindsey graham's
argument or donald trump's argument or
our argument
today and keep in mind it is also tough
though he did make this argument before
i don't want
i don't want our argument to rest on
that exhibit
because josephine is the same guy who
who said this
and perhaps most cruelly of all
if donald trump has his way the
complications from covert 19
which are well beyond
what they should be it's estimated that
200 million people
have died probably by the time i finish
this
talk 200 200 million
people who died but if that's
only seven million cases
[Music]
he's [ __ ] right is that what i think
that's what he determines is that his
takeaway
approximately do i need christopher
plummer to show up in my imagination
yeah exactly yeah that echo is just
walking out like who's ready to rock and
it's just one guy
yeah i really want can you set my mic
to uh uh sad peter frampton guitar
[Laughter]
you know where most people leave halfway
into the show
it was a full rally at the beginning
the crowd leaves that is the biden that
is the biden rally it's like
finding out who the winner is at
medieval times like i don't care if it's
red or blue
it doesn't matter it doesn't affect my
life i'm out let's go before the lot is
filled with
angered two-year-olds and sippy cups the
chickens sucked again
every time okay so here's another
argument they use well it isn't legally
oppressed at half a year endorsement so
they say well what about decorum
okay um let me be really clear about
this because i do believe that
conservatives need to be consistent i've
tried to talk about this in the past
however let's talk about sort of the
decorum pr
precedent that's been set when you
knowingly slander a
man to be a gang rapist as you did with
kavanaugh
in front of his wife in front of his
family in front of the entire
world knowing verifiably that it's false
or at the very least
completely baseless guess what you
rewrote the rule book
we don't owe you anything you're going
to say it's unprecedented when 29 times
in american history a situation like
this has happened
10 times a situation like this has
happened exactly with nine of these
justices
actually being confirmed we had the same
presidential party and senate
and you want to tell us it's a violation
of decorum we just don't do this
we're going to we're going to was it
chuck schumer said nothing is off the
table we're going to go nuclear well
really hold on a second again with the
threats it's like the threats when they
say if rpg's seat is replaced we're
going to violently protest well you've
already committed two billion dollars
in damage and took over eight city
blocks in a city that nobody likes
[ __ ]
what else you got at this point think oh
we're gonna go to a nuclear option oh
really a nuclear option
you labeled this guy a gang rapist you
made it sound
like he was trying to run a train on a
woman like the baseball furies for
crying out loud
what else is there what other nuclear
options so you throughout the rule book
we are beholden to nothing
yeah nothing at this point yeah fill the
c sorry rbg i wish that i'd been soft
well and in the the chuck todds of the
world were carrying their water this
weekend just going ballistic on
republicans saying that they can't
believe they would do something like
this i'd love for you to
rewind a little bit to 2016 when the
merrick garland situation happened did
were they up in arms then i mean i don't
remember seeing cnn and msnbc and
everybody else
saying no no no you should not be a new
president is coming in one way or the
other because you're going out right you
should definitely wait
and using joe biden's words against him
that nobody did that nobody brought that
up and by the way it's just
it's it's this simple barack obama not
had him not nominated he he nominated
what were the terms where the order
nominate
confirmation yeah nominate the nominate
from confirmed than a point
nominate confirm a point barack obama
did use his authority he did nominate a
supreme court justice and the senate
said
yeah that's that's our system of checks
and balances
no so now you know how i wanted you to
confirm
my my nominee mm-hmm yeah we're not
going to do that they didn't have the
votes right
so you know and that's what's crazy is
that they're relying on the decor back
then they were like well
normally these guys would just sail
through well we're not letting them sail
through this time
none of the arguments are about the
actual power right right right now
then or now not not a one of the
arguments are actually
wait a minute we have the law on our
side the law says xyz instead they're
just having to say
we really don't like the way that this
would look we're really serious about it
or so
i mean they do it very quickly but i
can't even muster the no it deforms out
the window when you're burning down
cities
right it's just done at this point i
agree with that and i understand that
but at the same time you do what's right
even when it's inconvenient right that's
what i would go back to and you even
said that like you want to make sure
that you're consistent
consistency right now would be telling
every democrat who has a problem with
this to look back at 2016 because they
should and look back at it
yeah exactly look back at what joe biden
said nothing is happening
out of the ordinary this is completely
out of the ordinary the president
is going to nominate a supreme court
justice the senate is likely going to
confirm it
and you can go fornicate yourself with a
wire brush yeah and here's here's a
reason they say
let the people speak and that was what
they said in 2016. when you have a
senate divided
the judiciary rests with the the white
house and the senate
and when people put people why you gotta
bring race into no
i didn't say that son of a [ __ ] when
the people vote for the same party
they're saying i i like your judicial
philosophy go for it do what you need to
do that's exactly what happened here
when they vote somebody else in
right basically what the people are
saying is we don't like your judicial
philosophy
don't go ahead the people have already
spoken yep that doesn't need to happen
they've spoken again in every single
midterm too adding more republicans to
the senate by the way
hit the notification bell if you are
watching this uh because subscriptions
don't mean a whole lot on youtube we do
this
show every morning monday through
thursday at 10 00 a.m and do consider
joining
we have a major announcement by the way
regarding michigan
uh the state capitol in lansing on
october 2nd the big show the biggest
thing we've ever done on that friday
it's huge so find your way on down to
that's lansing state capital in
whitmer's backyard where she takes poops
uh on october 2nd i didn't know that
that's news to me yeah that is news uh
here's the final argument now they go to
norms and institutions right they go to
decorum this is kind of different it's
kind of all the same because they don't
really have a legacy
but norms and institutions um the point
that they're making right now
is that uh well it's tradition right
hold on tradition we've already kind of
dispelled that
um but they've been trying to pack we
talk about norms and institutions
keep in mind this is the party that
wants to do away with the electoral
college
okay this is the party to add seats
and by the way are they do they want the
filibuster they want to ban the
filibuster
it depends who's president at that point
year to year
we want the filibuster all right listen
it's like it's like asking a guy to go
in the back and pick something free oh
is this just a display model of this
lg do you have any more let me go check
in the back and he brings it out and you
go actually now i want a panasonic
like all right he goes back he comes
back like actually now i want a
westinghouse because i lost my job and
i hear those are more affordable it's
effectively an off brand
we don't sell westinghouse at best buy
sir that's walmart well you know what i
guess i'm going to take my cash
elsewhere
that's what they're doing with the
filibuster they want to talk norms and
institutions they don't want us to
continue with the electoral college be
clear about that okay they don't want us
to accept the results of the elections
they don't want us to actually
uh conduct elections the way that we've
always conducted ever yeah elections
yeah um and they want to pack the
supreme court keep in mind
they're complaining about something that
is entirely within not only
constitutional parameters but
histori historically has been a standard
set
they have been clear that if biden is
elected they want to change
all of it and pack the courts here you
go if
in fact they are successful in placing a
justice
on the court i think that what democrats
have to do
assuming that biden is president and
there is a a senate majority in for the
democrats
we need to think about court reform and
at a minimum
as part of that reform package i think
additional justices need to be placed on
the uh on the supreme court
i don't care if photo negative ned
flanders
yeah that that's okay that's court
reform or that's courtroom
so basically you don't like the reform
usually mean like bringing it back to
its original
purpose or intent yeah there's that
pesky constitution they don't like
either they want to get they want to
rewrite
that as well ever since it raped jimmy
carter pretty much
no no that's a sad day for him
peanut farmer farmer everyone else it
was just another day
um so let's be really clear that's what
they want to do they're clear about it
they've said don't accept the results of
the election
big media this is also important when i
say big media big tech we talk about
this really they're one and the same
with the
the leftist government right now uh
because they follow lockstep with the
same policies when you have effectively
hillary clinton coming out saying
under no circumstances should joe biden
concede and then you have jack dorsey
and you have people on
twitter i don't know if zuckerberg
joined in or who did it alphabet but i
know jack dorsey did
in no uncertain terms when they join in
with hillary clinton echoing her
sentiment saying
we will remove any misinformation that
claims on election day that donald trump
has won
listen the two are inextricably tied the
current dnc
and big tech they're working together
also because they understand that the
dnc will offer protections
to them uh with a double standard that
they would not offer to other companies
again that's
why all i want i don't want them to
necessarily be declared a public
platform i want social media companies
to have to determine and answer are you
a public platform are you a public
square are you a publisher because
two very different rule sets one is what
you use now to be afforded these legal
these legal loopholes these legal
protections while you still selectively
implement the law the other okay well
then you're just like the new york times
and you can uh
censor your comment pages all you want
but you need to decide
so i want to be clear about that and
finally the last thing the argument is
is the dying wish well okay
i you know what jiminy cricket can can
go screw himself i don't give a rack
i don't give a rats as if there was a
shooting star if it was a solar eclipse
they're saying oh her dying wish which
no one can verify by the way it's like a
tmz
story 87 it's not like she was saying it
to john cena
you don't just get a diamond really yeah
and then she was reiterating it to her
granddaughter i told john cena
but he just kept doing this
[Laughter]
what is this i was very confused
he said they brought the ice cream
sandwiches
which is all i can suggest oh my gosh i
needed blending and
soup yeah you know when you're your
strongest argument is dying wish
you're screwed well look let's let's
let's take a quote from her when she
wasn't dying
uh she said when asked if the senate
should consider justice in election year
this was uh rbg's response she said
that's their job there's nothing in the
constitution that says the president
stops being the president
in his last year so it changed you know
john cena confused her
listen let's let bygones be bygones okay
we can't hold her at her word but we
certainly shouldn't hold her
granddaughter
at her was it daughter or granddaughter
another girl was her granddaughter
because her daughter probably wouldn't
remember the dying wish her daughter was
probably there
some some kind of uh maybe son was like
i heard the dying wish so it wasn't he's
like i don't remember because i'm also
85.
you know you know what's one thing
there's a very telling admission of that
is that if there was a time that you
were going to use a dying wish to say
something you would use it to say oh
the law says you can't do xyz and for
all of her
faults or the opinions that i disagreed
with that she authored she was a very
brilliant legal scholar
and a very brilliant legal scholar and
her dying wish
was not the law says you can't do it it
was
i prefer that it'd not be that way right
and that is an honest admission
unlike what we're hearing from the dems
which is there are there's legal hurdles
oh there's a blah blah blah no
no no you may not like it but they wish
them's the rules
kind of like when you often say like i
wish i could kick gerald in the nuts
right now well he doesn't
do it while the cameras are rolling no
no look i don't want to disrupt the flow
of the show
i can i can find him in the parking lot
after it's challenging
when you wish upon a star bam
my balls that hurts that's rbg's wish
that's about what i think of it
uh okay we are going to you should
uh go who are not mug club members we're
going to play a bad movie line and we
have a major announcement to make
here exclusively for mukbang members
youtube we uh would love to say that we
love you but we can't say it because we
we don't love to say that we love things
if we don't necessarily love them but we
would love to be able to talk about love
but for right now
a piss off